the mystery over the disappearance of a
texas teen and a new documentary that
aims to help solve the cold case caleb
deal didn't show up for school one
morning in a small texas town and has
not been seen since
he was a high school senior at the time
in 2015 family friend ricky howard was
named a person of interest in the
disappearance but was never charged for
caleb's case is covered in the new
season of the hit documentary series
never seen again from our streaming
service paramount plus which highlights
missing person cases in hopes of getting
answers take a look at this clip
i put together this notebook all of the
answers are right here
except where is caleb
where is caleb deal
happy birthday
to
you
happy birthday just a month of march
i hate it because it's his birthday and
then two weeks after his 18th birthday
he disappeared
caleb told his sister that he was going
to visit a friend the night he
disappeared but it turns out that that
friend wasn't even in town
everything was wrong none of the plans
that he had made none of that was going
forward he had essentially driven off
and vanished and nobody knew anything i
only got one phone call from howard
about caleb missing
and it was
strangely cold and short very unlike
someone who'd been like a brother to you
he gave the reason why he believed caleb
was missing he was going to go help a
girlfriend's relative and work somewhere
in oklahoma there was no way he would
just leave and not tell a single soul
ricky's making stuff up about what could
have possibly happened to caleb why
would he do that that makes no sense
suddenly tammy deal makes a disgusting
frightening discovery inside her own
home
i've worked missing persons cases over
the years i cannot think of one that has
ended
like this case
[Applause]
wow ginger allen who we saw in that clip
is a reporter at our dallas-fort worth
cbs station ktvt and joins us now ginger
good morning
good morning to you all
so you say that the deals made a bizarre
and upsetting discovery can you tell us
what it is
i can and it is bizarre so in 2017
that's two years after caleb has
disappeared the deals are inside their
house and they're cleaning and stashed
away in a hard to reach cabinet
they find a bag that they believe caleb
has hidden and inside that bag
investigators say they find evidence
that ricky howard the person of interest
has been practicing polygraph questions
practicing how to answer questions about
his interest in underage boys not only
that but they also find a clock radio
with a hidden camera inside and images
from that camera lead investigators to
eventually learn that ricky howard has
been abusing caleb and other boys for
years before he ever disappeared
i know and ginger i watched both
episodes i was only going to watch one
but you were so good the piece was so
good i said i want to see what happens
they have a great moment where the
father caleb's dad confronts ricky
howard we can talk about that people
have to watch it but i'm curious because
you talked to tammy the mom the day
after this aired what does she say to
you what is she thinking and feeling
so she and i talked yesterday for a long
time gail um she's very happy with the
documentary series she's very encouraged
and she's very hopeful that this brings
someone forward who has some answers she
seems to think there's someone out there
who may be afraid to come forward she
also is on a letter writing campaign
because ricky howard is now in prison on
sexual exploitation charges but this
missing case missing person's case is
wide open
she plans for her and her or her family
to start sending letters to ricky howard
every week she told me yesterday she
will never forget and she doesn't want
him to forget she 100 percent believes
he knows something i'm a mom gayle
and i know every parent out there can
relate to this i have a 19 year old son
who looked like caleb my heart breaks
for her
mine too anybody who watches that piece
is going to want to write a letter to
ricky howard
ginger thank you very much it's so true
and just hope he has answers
yep yeah thank you uh all right you can
watch the second season of never seen
again right now i'm paramount plus thank
you ginger